Let's talk about how we fix that issue. Ginger makes it
easy to do this. There are two ways, I'll show you the
way that's simplest first. They've got the syntax for adding a
pipe and then a filter. There are a couple, there are lots
of built in features in the Ginger. One of them is
called escape. So if you say when you print your item, if
you say pipe escape, it'll actually get escaped. Let's see what
this looks like in our browser. Now when I reload this page,
the junk is actually getting escaped. And if I
look at the source code for this page, we can
see down here that Ginger ran it through an HTML
escaping function and replaced the less than symbol with ampersand
less than, and the greater than symbol with ampersand
greater than. Just like we did in the previous lesson.
And again, you can see that down here with the
h1. But that's not how I prefer to do things
in any templating language. Because it's a little error prone.
If you forget to put this in, you've got a
security hole. There is another way around this, however. If
you go, when you initialize Ginger, if you say this, auto
escape equals true, Ginger will automatically escape all variable substitutions.
So let's make sure this is still working in our
browser. I reload this page, trust me I reloaded it,
nothing changed. If we check our source code, again nothing changed.
We can see it's all skipped properly here. The reason I like
to do this, is that prevents you from accidentally making a mistake.
It's a lot easier to see that oh, I need to deal
with this input when it's here, than it is to see a
subtle error or you know, not be able to see it at
all when a user is trying to hack your website. So I
always, in every templating language that I use, look for the equivalent
of auto escape equals two. And so far every one I have used
has something along this line. Now what if you actually want
to display the HTML? Well, there is a filter for just
that. And you can say safe, pipe safe. And so if
you know the HTML is safe, you can undo it this way,
and I feel like this is the best way, you to
opt in to the unsafe way rather than opting in to the
safe way. So if I save this and we go back
to our browser and I reload this page, we can see that
it is rendering unsafely again. But at least this time we
did it on purpose, we knew what to expect. And you
do this if you want to you know, sanitize the out
put a little bit. For example if your building a comment page
and you want the uses to have some amount of formatting
but not everything. You can only allow certain things and then
print it using this filter. But anyways, let's get that out
of here because we don't, we don't trust our shopping cart users.